ciao ragazzi ben tornato il nuovo
puntata di ciao ragazzi bentornati a una
puntata di ciao ragazzi bentornati una
nuova puntata di vita buttata il tema
della puntata di oggi è nord contro sud
ok sud contro nord io direi di
utilizzare a questo punto la cosa che ci
vede più comoda contro diciamo che io ho
già iniziato a sudare da giorni non
tanto perché abbia paura dei commenti
razzisti che sicuramente arriveranno e
che dovremmo che in qualche modo
togliere scusate non siamo il canale
giusto per promuovere l'odio ma per le
persone che ho pensato di invitare avevo
un pochino di dubbi se invitare una
persona del nord una del sud
ecco perché ho pensato di invitare
all'interno degli studios di casa mia
una ragazza del nord che qualcuno di voi
già si ricorda da un mio video
precedente sto parlando della mia amica
valentina ciao qualcuno di voi potrà
tacciarmi del fatto di aver chiamato una
persona del nord che ci sta ed è per
questo che ho pensato in verità di
invitare una ragazza del sud
mia cugina vittoria chiaro allora sei
molto contenta moltissimo via no io non
ti sopporto ecco perché ho pensato di
invitare un mio cugino del sud
paolo ciao a tutti se ti dico facciamo
che ci stanno tutti e tre da i benvenuti
ragazzi fai un po
ma che sei una professione se per metro
perché non riesce a leggere
per fortuna ci sei tu paolo perché una
bruttissima pubblicità
siccome abbiamo due catanesi qua è
solamente una milanese ho deciso di
patteggiare da romano per il nord quindi
web dica io mia mamma andata carta di
credito o sperare tacca ha tirato un po
il figlio mi sento un po di svantaggio
negata pochino comunque si può dire che
al milano dicono grafica al sud dicono
mi impianti fa capire qual è il posto
superiore sempre promosso contraddirlo
[Risate]
parlo per la provincia di caserta e
dalle mie parti c'è questo modo di dire
abbastanza e rurale che tu sì o no
perché tu sei un uomo non il maiale
perché almeno questo è quello che
abbiamo cercato di ricostruire non so
esattamente se è così che magari video
ci sono un anno per cui non ha tempo di
maturare di diventare grande infatti il
maiale viene usato anche come unità di
misura cioè un ragazzino delega 13 anni
vuol dire rendere 11 anni ha capito la
tengo a 12 anni più un maiale conviene a
13 sono alto un maiale e mezzo
motivo per cui il sud è un posto brutto
è che al sud persone come lui a 11 anni
ti raccontano la trama rit
io per tutta l'estate per colpa sua non
ho chiuso occhio
qualche da scusa tu ora dice sunny un
porto per ragazzi a milano dicono mi è
preso dentro per caso ti sembra una cosa
volgare
no qui per caso di urto ti ho preso
dentro scusa
l'altro problema grandissimo è come voi
tendete paccare come noi intendiamo paga
mai mancare non si dice no io come mia
cugina lavinia lancia un appello ai
rugbisti e mia cugina spaccare la noia
quando mi hai tirato il pacco quindi non
ti sei presentato prima volta dove
vedere un mio amico arrivo con lui io ti
dico che mi ha attaccato a roma paccare
vuol dire baciare intensamente che
sarebbe limonare del nord al impone io
sono una rarità
tutte ragazze siciliane anima e ragazze
mamma parlapiano prego vendo mia mamma
per 10 9 un po di respiro
dici qualcosa anche beatrice l'abbiamo
persa noi andiamo avanti
lei va a piangere da balconi e piegata
vabbè dei ragazzi che quando devi dire
che qualcuno non ti presta interesse non
si sta spostando e ci sono non fissa non
mi sta pensando che poi corrisponde a
noi a milano ok diciamo non mi caga per
non è che cagare in realtà e mi ha
pisciato vuol dire che mai ha cannato mi
hai peccato mi hai smollato non sei
venuto ma è lento non me l'ha data dice
mi hai la mia la città intere dc o da
ali falli paolo a catania si dice mi hai
lasciato in 13 e come dice quando non
viene un appuntamento ma calma
[Risate]
ospite perché il sud specie in sicilia
sono convinti che il cibo sei migliori
al mondo così sta dappertutto cd
fantastici come giapponese messicano
ps io stesso sono siciliano non
scherziamo che cosa cioè cucina
siciliana e basta noi anche
ammazza ospite ecc a tutta famiglia di
ultimi anni che sostituito a nord che
sto siciliana come te e sono stati in
crisi perché quando in volta che dice ma
tovaglia non riuscendo mai a capirlo è
per noi la tovaglia e la tovaglia da
mare a quella per metterla sul tavolo la
tua vera è quella del bagno a nord la
tomaia è solo una che non mi chiedevo
alla nostro settore del tavolo in
sopportando quando mi chiedono passami
la tovaglia io li guardo nissim e li
lascia morire di freddo perché non
esiste non si può dire il sud più avuto
critico del nord non indica nord a tutti
ma siamo troppo bravi ma critica il sud
o tovaglia fate cagare il pensiero sogus
ospite io sono veramente del sito della
francia di salerno e il è vicina casa di
domenica al tè del pomeriggio hanno a
polla questa musica neomelodica
[Musica]
riguarda è una di vita buttata sono
stati quando vado in vacanza in puglia
praticamente i miei mi dici di là per
chiedere di uscire fanno nasta in scendo
stasera usando il circuito indicate una
cosa al futuro e per me dai ragazzi
veramente non potete far pagare 50
centesimi bicchiere d'acqua al bar
noi paghiamo anche la panna surgela con
pagate avevano soggiornato non credo mi
sa che a roma nella seconda gara tutto
una porzione 10 porto non è vero
vogliamo ah beh non è vero il ketchup
maionese donors e noi ancora non ne
paghiamo
certo perché mi chiedi dopo youtube ai
chiedi tutto fed ordinato diventati la
sorte marley la samp il latrocinio
destra
[Risate]
posso fare una critica al nord ma non ha
mai critico alber stesso faccio una
critica grammaticale comunque la scusa
grammaticale palla
martino mi spiace ospite che sono un
ragazzo siciliano che si è trasferito a
milano per studiare come dice è una cosa
che non ho mai capito nei milanesi e
penso un po anche con i ragazzi del nord
in generale è la fretta che fretta c'è
sempre di corsa poi soprattutto una cosa
riguardo la fretta usano asap c'è questa
abitudine di traslitterare l'italiano in
inglese causare esmen ies possible casa
ma parla italiano
la simpatia siciliana che ha scelto
questi audio ora diciamo qualcosa di
cattivo nei confronti del sud le spiagge
che sono dei patrimoni meravigliosi sono
che tenuta di mare inquinato abbiamo
problemi dei depuratori costruite sulla
spiaggia proprio le attaccato e inutile
continuare a togliere so perché si sa
noi del sud siamo troppo belli più
fievole sempre cosi per sono io
però lì ci sono comunque ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video io
ringrazio paolo valentina e basta per e
vittorio cia per aver preso parte a
questo mio video grazie ragazzi io non
so che tipo di commenti riceveremo sotto
questo video un pochino di ansia vi
prego rimaniamo tutti quanti polight
perché secondo me la grande lezione che
ho imparato oggi è che al di là
dell'essere meridionali o settentrionali
siamo tutti quanti italiani e io
l'italia un posto meraviglioso
il motivo per cui è bello viverci ed è
bello condividerlo con gli altri tranne
per provare ecco questo qui è una cosa
che vorrei lasciarmi alle spalle e
rispondiamo facciamo tutto qui allora io
vi lascio qua sotto
le contrazioni del ma come sempre
l'invito innanzitutto a seguire questi
ragazzi vi lascio i loro link qua sotto
di instagram iscrivervi a questo canale
e attivare la campagna nelle notifiche
per non perdere gli altri video
noi ci vediamo la prossima settimana
sempre 14 con un altro vita buttata ciao
oddio mamma